ich bin traurig meine frage an euch ist
das noch durch mehr spaß video stream
oder live auftritte ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr auf meine frage
antworten könnte hallo tami danke für
die gute frage sehr interessant
ja live auftritt oder video es hat
irgendwie beides seine reize ist macht
beides sehr spaß jetzt zum beispiel
ständer timer sich mal wieder richtig
gepackt aber auch die live-auftritte
sind halt richtig cool weil du bekommst
dann sofort feedback vom publikum
die gehen ab mit dir zusammen singen
vielleicht sogar die texte mit und das
ist echt total cool das andere wenn da
was schief läuft dann läuft schief man
kann nichts rausschneiden und ja es ist
beides sehr cool macht uns beiden beides
sehr viel spaß